In the last lesson, you did a bunch
of data analysis using Python.
And you did use NumPy and
matplotlib a bit, but for the most part,
you completed the analysis without
using any additional libraries.
In this lesson, you're going to get
a lot more familiar with NumPy.
And I'll also introduce you
to a library called pandas.
Both of these libraries,
especially Pandas take a little
time to learn how to use.
But once you do, they'll make writing
data analysis code a lot easier.
And your code will also run
faster when you use them.
When I first started using Pandas,
I spent a lot of time reading online
documentation, going through tutorials
and I found it really difficult.
This course contains the information
I wish I'd had when I started out.
I won't be able to cover every feature
that you might want to use, but
by the end, you'll be better equipped
to read the documentation and
learn more on your own.
In this lesson, I'll be focusing on
using NumPy and Pandas to analyze one
dimensional data, so something like
a single column of a spreadsheet.
Let's get started